Ciao! Lo so, la finale degli Europei 2020 non è stata facile per nessuno.
Ci sono state delle liti, delle risse,
dei tafferugli, alberi sono stati buttati fuori dalle finestre,
birre lanciate in aria.
C’è chi si è tatuato in maniera sconsiderata prima del tempo,
ci sono state persone che hanno fischiato per 75 minuti di fila
contro qualsiasi cosa l’Italia facesse,
persino durante l’inno Nazionale.
Ci sono stati dei commenti razzisti contro la squadra dell’Inghilterra,
fatti per altro da inglesi.
Beh, anche dall’altra parte è stata tosta.
Chiellini ha addirittura tirato una maglia e poi, beh, certo, c’è stata la nostra vittoria.
So che perdere non è mai semplice,
davvero conosco la sensazione, io perdo in continuazione
e ciò che faccio quando le cose si mettono davvero storte
è cucinarmi un buon pasto.
Oggi voglio fare pace con l’Inghilterra
e in questo momento sto per preparare un piatto italiano
nella sua versione inglese
solo per dimostrare che possiamo essere gentili gli uni con gli altri.
La ricetta che ho deciso di cucinare è un capolavoro italiano: la carbonara.
Io vengo da Roma, questo piatto è tipicamente romano
e io sono a tutti gli effetti il re indiscusso della carbonara… auto proclamato…
Ma ciò che voglio fare oggi è provare la versione inglese
ed è per questo che ho scelto la ricetta di Jamie Oliver.
Per vostra informazione Jamie Oliver è ancora ricercato in alcune parti dell’Italia
quindi se doveste avvistarlo tenetelo lontano dal nostro paese,
per la sua stessa sicurezza.
Senza ulteriore indugio, iniziamo con la lista degli ingredienti.
Per fare la carbonara inglese ci servirà:
Un uovo, che è un buon punto di partenza ad essere onesti. Ben fatto Inghilterra.
Del pepe macinato. Molto molto bene, sono orgoglioso di voi.
Cheddar. Sapete una cosa? Non sono qui per giudicare,
voglio essere il più aperto mentalmente possibile perciò Cheddar sia.
Il mio cuore sta iniziando a spezzarsi…
Bacon. Un rametto di rosmarino che può essere usato come aspersorio
per l’acqua santa durante un qualche tipo di rituale, spero. Aglio...
Perché?
Olio d’oliva, bravo ragazzo. E infine pasta.
Ragazzi, oggi fa veramente caldo qui,
fatemi prendere una pausa e poi comincerò a cucinare.
Procediamo. Tutti insieme!
Ma prima di cominciare. Questo è uno scherzo, ok?
Se venite in Italia e provano a rifilarvi un piatto di pasta,
come una carbonara, a 20 euro è solo per turisti.
Stanno cercando di fregarvi quindi mandateli a quel paese, non esiste.
Prima di tutto ci tengo a ringraziare il sito chatelaine.com
dove ci siamo procurati la ricetta per la carbonara di Jamie Oliver.
“Jamie Oliver è venuto a trovarci nella nostra cucina
e ha condiviso con noi alcune delle ricette tratte dal suo nuovo libro:
Risparmiate con Jamie”. Che presto diventerà Risparmiate Jamie, temo.
Solo per vostra informazione, questo show non è uno show professionale,
è uno show alla cazzo di cane
quindi non aspettatevi che io sia preciso o un esperto del settore,
come alcuni food blogger o cuochi online fingono di essere.
La prima cosa che faremo è cucinare la pasta.
Perché stiamo usando le penne lisce?
Lo sapete che queste, questo tipo di pasta, è illegale in Italia?
Devo andare sul mercato nero per procurarmi questa mostruosità.
Ragazzi, usate quelle rigate, per favore, non quelle lisce.
Perché? Non so proprio perché.
Affettare il bacon e friggetelo in padella con un filo d’olio d’oliva.
Perché un filo d’olio quando c’è già questo?
Li abbiamo già i grassi. Un filo… oh ca**o.
Ora sto cercando di tagliarlo grossolanamente.
Mi dispiace molto aver comprato delle fette così sottili di bacon,
è solo che non mi andava di passare dal macellaio.
Non sono riuscito a trovare quelli dello spessore giusto
perciò non giudicherò troppo aspramente questo ingrediente,
perché se non hai quello originale non puoi commentarlo.
Perciò sì, scusatemi, sono pigro.
Ora, quando il bacon diventa croccante e leggermente dorato
è arrivato il momento di aggiungere l’aglio.
Ragazzi, questo procedimento mi spezza il cuore, è peggio del finale del Titanic.
Avete presente quando Leo affonda lentamente nell’oceano?
È la stessa cosa che sto per fare adesso mentre guardo questo aglio
sprofondare pian piano in un mare di grassi animali.
Facciamolo insieme.
Italiani se state guardando questo video non venitemi a prendere
ma il profumo in realtà è buono. No? Smella buono.
Un pizzico di pepe. Un rametto di Rosmarino. Ok, eccolo.
Ora lo mescoliamo per bene e spegnete il fuoco.
La parte più difficile è creare  l’iconica salsa della carbonara,
che deve essere cremosa e formaggiosa e ricca d’uovo, giallo-aranciata…
ma noi faremo la versione inglese, quindi incominciamo con il cheddar.
Ok, cerchiamo di fare del nostro meglio tagliandolo finemente,
ok non è troppo difficile.
Oh sì, Sì. *suoni erotici*.
In realtà è molto soddisfacente da fare.
La prossima mossa è aggiungere un uovo al cheddar,
che in realtà è la cosa che mi rende più agitato, al momento,
poiché non c’è il pecorino
che è il formaggio a cui sono abituato. Possiamo farcela.
Il tempo è giunto, possiamo finalmente scolare la pasta.
Questa è una cosa che facciamo qui in Italia,
non so se si fa anche nel resto del mondo
ma mentre scoliamo la pasta,
dal momento che l’acqua è davvero bollente di solito
apriamo il rubinetto e lasciamo scorrere l’acqua fredd
per non danneggiare lo scolo del lavandino.
Non so nemmeno se io abbia parlato in lingua inglese,
spero abbiate capito comunque.
Ora riaccendiamo il fornello del condimento…
Non so cosa sia successo.
Per favore… ok.
E adesso il momento finale. Un momento che è davvero difficile da guardare,
immaginate di essere qui al posto mio e doverlo fare: aggiungere l’uovo.
Ciò che Jamie suggerisce è di spegnere il fuoco
o rischiare di ritrovarvi con delle uova strapazzate. Bravo Jamie.
Mescolate.
Aspettate 10 secondi, o almeno è quello che di solito faccio io, perciò:
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 3…no 4, 3, 2, 1. Andiamo.
Sono un po’ confuso da questa salsa perché è molto cremosa
ma allo stesso tempo quando la sollevate, vedete? Lo vedete?
Ci sono come dei filamenti… beh, le darò un’occasione,
vediamo com’è quella che Jamie Oliver considera una carbonara inglese.
Allora, questo è il risultato finale,
l’assaggerò e ve la descriverò come farebbe Nigella.
Avvolgente. Vorrei farla scivolare lungo la mia gola, sentirne il calore,
la scioglievolezza, la succulenza,
inumidirmi fino alle gonadi. Dio salvi la regina e me.
Allora c’è qualcosa di profondamente sbagliato in questa ricetta,
tipo il formato della pasta.
Ripugnante. Non mi dispiace la salsa…
è abbastanza formaggiosa, un po’ appiccicosa, si sente molto il cheddar…
non ha niente a che vedere con  la carbonara,
almeno non con quella  italiana,
ovvio è la versione inglese ma il tipo di pasta!
Come fate a mangiarla?
Perché la comprate? Perché la suggerite?!
Jamie che ca**o stavi pensando quando hai consigliato le penne lisce?
Le darò un 6, su 10.
Più 5, non è il mio genere.
Ragazzi, amici, spero questo video vi sia piaciuto, di solito non li giro in inglese,
vi chiedo scusa se ho fatto degli errori o detto qualcosa di sbagliato,
non è la mia lingua madre , quindi, per favore, siate caritatevoli.
Per i miei amici italiani,
We wanted to try something new,
especially to export our kitchen around the world.
Ma tornando a voi, se vi è piaciuto questo video potete iscrivervi a questo canale
o imparare a fare la vera carbonara,
cliccando più o meno qui. È in italiano
quindi fatemi sapere se doveste volerne una versione inglese
che potrei pubblicare su un altro canale
Perché non voglio mettere troppe cose inglesi qui.
Questa era solo una prova,
spero che stiate tutti bene e vi mando un bacio. Ciao!
Ciao ragazzi, io sono Gianpazzo.
Troppo! Non è troppo cattiva, ma neanche buona.
Non è una Carbonara.
È, come si dice in italiano, un "mappazzone". Non benissimo!
Ciao ragazzi, io sono Enrico e adesso provo questa carbonara,
se possiamo chiavarla Carbonara
Scusate per il mio brutto inglese. L'odore è molto buono. Mi piace!
I'm thinking about grammar
Mi dispiace ma... il test è fallito. Non è una carbonara. È un buon...